well concerts are definitely back in
full swing this summer and we caught up
with the stars who are dishing on their
pre-show rituals
[Music]
we do a circle circle we do a prayer we
do a affirmation there's a tiny sermon
maybe
you're at the gym almost
[Applause]
green juice
in the morning and here at night
[Music]
i try to spend time in silence and then
warm up stretch i do the same thing but
with a little bit of vodka
i usually mix a drink it always starts
with a shot of whiskey for sure even
when i sing at church i take a shot i
used to drink whiskey like a fish before
going out on stage and now i do like
vocal warm-ups that i drink the whiskey
after
a little tea before a little prayer
before we head out and go on stage gary
underwood also eats the exact same thing
every show day not better bars for
breakfast hummus and veggies for lunch
two scrambled eggs and half an avocado
for dinner while keith urban gets guitar
ready for the stage by strumming on the
banjo for wife nicole kidman
just trying to stay loose
yeah stay loose
[Music]
we all do this vocal exercises
[Music]
[Music]
like
it looks weird it's weird so weird
[Music]
dirk's bentley hits the bat uh trying to
spend like
15 minutes a day in an ice in a trash
can full of ice john legend eats half a
rotisserie chicken as for jesse james
decker i like to have a bone and rib eye
so i like to have a big piece of steak
with a baked potato
and asparagus and i like my steak medium
rare
[Music]